so is it just me or is this whole world
getting a bit crazy right now I want to
make this video about the golden rule as
it's called but before I get to that let
me share with you what brought me to
being inspired to make this video so
about a week week and a half ago I was
out of town for a wedding and I had a
number of different just great
conversations catching up with old
friends and a bunch of different people
there and I got to chatting with some
people about how I'm making you know I'm
doing a YouTube channel and I one of the
conversations that stood out and
actually let me just mention that I
asked a number of different people what
it is they would say to humanity like
seven if you had the audience of seven
plus billion people right now you could
say something to them give a message
what would it be and one of the
conversations that stood out and then we
also mentioned that a lot of people said
similar things that people need to be
nicer to each other people need to just
stop freaking out about money people
talked about how this whole world is
being controlled by the few which stood
out to me obviously if you listen to my
other videos but one of the
conversations is stood out was from the
mother of the bride and I had a real
nice candid conversation with her and I
asked her luckily if you could say
anything to humanity what would it be
and she said literally people need to
start being more kind to one another and
they got me thinking about the golden
rule as it's commonly called you know
treat people the way you want to be
treated so to speak and now when I was
in my undergrad I got my minor in
religious studies couple reasons wanting
these is a GPA booster and I knew that a
lot of these classes according to rate
my professor com was like easy aids you
could take a lot of them online and do
discussion posts but that aside I
learned a lot of things in the process
and I also took one to take those
classes because I just find it
interesting that most of the world's
population is religious now me
personally I'm not religious I was
raised Catholic I don't I concern myself
non-religious I'm a spiritual guy I
believe that we're spiritual beings
inhabiting a body and that essentially I
say that nature's in my church and love
is my religion and I'm a seeker of truth
and that there's a lot of there's a lot
of truths within religion but there's a
lot of things that you know the most
common religions in the world just seem
to omit or don't discuss or you know so
I'll just leave it at that so you know
where I'm coming from but are you aware
that the thirteen most common religions
in the world that the base the most sin
this foundation of every single one at
least 13 most common religions is
literally the golden rule now they all
were did a little bit differently and
let me give you some examples I know
that the prints on there is a little bit
too small to see so let me bring you up
this one that just shows nine of them so
you can see that they all have something
similar so Christianity has an example a
quote you know from straight from
Scripture is and everything do to others
as you would have them do to you for
this is the law of the prophets so let's
skip over to Judaism what is hateful to
you do not do to your neighbor this is
the hole of a Torah all the rest is
commentary which I think is pretty
interesting if you think about it saying
that this is the most important thing
right Hinduism this is the sum of duty
do not do to others what would cause
pain if done to you Islam not one of you
truly believes until you wish for others
what you wish for yourself that's from
the Prophet Muhammad Buddhism treat not
others in ways that you yourself would
find hurtful they all basically say the
same thing that be nice to others just
as you want people to treat you and
everything will be fine and you know you
have like say the ten commandments as an
example or different rules and guidance
that all these religions details and
outline the ultimately just altom Utley
if you just follow the golden rule
everything works out right but the
problem in that you know so many people
you know the world's population is
religious the percentage of this varies
I've tried to look you know most people
believe in a divine being
not everyone's religious so keep that in
mind but is it just me or di are you and
you must know people that are
quote-unquote religious they don't seem
to follow the golden rule on a even
close to a regular basis right even good
people people you think very highly of
you see that their egos get the better
of them maybe more often than not right
and in one of it you know one of the
things that comes back to is a lot of
people say respect is a two-way street
right now what I'm saying right now I
myself have also like followed a
significant majority in my life kind of
saying the same thing like I believe
being nice to others there's been plenty
times reven nice to others that weren't
very nice to me but there's been a whole
bunch of times where others have crossed
my path and I cross it right back over
to teach them right teach them a lesson
when people cross you you teach them
that it's not nice and
and you should shove it right back in
their face right so yeah that doesn't
work
the ego verse ego is an unwinnable
battle that only causes more suffering
and I remember hearing back in the day
you know people see you know people say
look you know by being mean to others
only inserting yourself in the process
and I always like kind of laugh that
often like it you know or scoffs it
obviously like you know well that's just
something people say to try and
encourage others to be nice right but
think about that when people cross you
when people disrespect you you know what
you're witnessing you're witnessing a
time capsule within them within
themselves their own life experiences
because we're all a product of our
experiences and we've had millions yes
millions of life experiences and what
you're witnessing with soin treats you
poorly is how others have treated them
in the past
think about that am I wrong when you
reflect on it you'll see just how true
it really is when you get to know people
like there's been a couple people I've
become very close friends with that when
we first met we didn't really hit it off
then really see eye to eye and we're
kind of weren't very nice to each other
and as we got to know each other we
realized that we all we both had flaws
within ourselves and if we come from
backgrounds that maybe you know we had
certain life experiences where you know
we felt we had been wronged and you seen
you carry those things but you it's a
subconscious thing right so when you
start to realize when you become aware
as I say that I am now that I'm aware
I'm awakened so to speak I mean every
day is a I feel like I'm waking up more
and more every day but you get to this
point where you start to figure out what
the underlying issue with humanity is is
that say these 13 most common religions
how many of them discuss in detail to
their followers the ego though the
workings of the human brain that
essentially guys we are an animal
species and just like any other animal
species we have personality
characteristics and part of the ego has
to do with denial projection that like
you know when people judge others for
example which is something humans do all
the time even if they don't do it out
loud and talk crap but others behind
their back beat in their brain and their
thoughts they'll think you know oh look
at that person look what they're wearing
look what they're doing look how that
person reacted to that Wow why would
they behave that way it is my belief
that we all are just operating based on
the experiences that we had and that
because we've walked in our individual
shoes for our entire lives no one can
truly
she ate you know or the experiences
you've had and why you racked certain
way in certain circumstances and that
essentially going back to the ego that
we weren't most of us weren't trained we
weren't trained in school about this we
weren't training religions we don't our
politicians don't discuss it
the news media doesn't discuss the ego
and how we can train ourselves to
identify that you know when people are
behaving like [ __ ] like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] excuse my language but
just trying to cater to every bit of all
my audience that essentially you're
witnessing how they've been treated by
others and they have they're just
oblivious to it looking back in my own
life and the times that I've treated
others poorly ie man I didn't think I
was treating other sport like I thought
I was justified I'm telling them this
because of what they just said or did to
me so they need to know that respect is
a two-way street and if you're going to
treat me poorly now you know what's
going to happen like like looking back
how much suffering did I caused others
how many how much suffering as any of us
caused others by simply responding to
their own ego right and how did it did
ever work out good even if that's a time
someone crossed you unjustly and you
cross them back and you get the win over
them essentially you you overpower their
personality and you I don't know you
shut them up or whatever did you feel
good about long-term couldn't you isn't
there like a subconscious part of you
that realized that that person was
having a really weak moment and you
pounded them basically where I'm going
with this and going back to my friend's
mother who says the whole world needs to
be more kind to one another
guys you are not helping this world by
giving by treating others poorly and
responding to their own ego or choosing
to the of the philosophy that respect is
a two-way street that for this world to
change it takes all of us in that you
need to be the change that you want to
be in the world right think about that
it only takes critical mass I'm not
suggesting here that 7 billion people
need to start being nice because I know
that doesn't not going to work like that
there's a sense of balance in the
universe that as above so below that
there is an opposite to everything so
you can have nice people you're gonna
have unhappy people angry people but you
can have enough people choosing
to treat others the way you would like
to be treated even when you come across
as a jerk like have you ever been the
person to maybe cross somebody else you
were you were and I have in a moment
you've had a bad day you kind of I don't
know we're rude to somebody unknowingly
by accident Union you know and it's hard
because this is part of the denial thing
you know people don't want to believe
that they've crossed others they don't
want to believe that they have been at
fault it's part of the human brain guys
this is like the workings of it I say
that it's the software of the hardware
brains the hardware egos the software
that denial is a hell of a thing and
most of this world thinks that they're
perfectly good people and have done no
wrong yet most of this world has
actually wronged others it's just part
of the human psyche it's part of the
game that we're in and that we're all
screwing over other people and some of
us just do it more than others so we
project we think oh well this person
does it worse than I do so you know they
need to worry about it not me so the
long story short is that the awareness
of that look namaste
realizing that what's and others is in
you the ability for you to be angry with
other people based on their actions is
because something within what they did
their actions is in with you is in you
as well that you are capable of it and
maybe you've done those negative actions
in the past I'm very I'm speaking very
philosophical from a from a very
philosophical standpoint right now so I
hope you're with me and I hope this is
making sense because this is completely
unscripted so to close this up we
reflect on the times that you have
wronged others and others of wrong deal
and think about how in the future moving
forward you can help make this world a
better place by actually living the
golden rule that when others cross you
say something like thank you like if
someone disrespects you says something
rude just say thank you you'll be amazed
to how people react it will often bring
them back to Planet Earth
they'll realize wait a second anyways
I'll leave it at that I just want to
give you all something to think about
but I'm Jimmy my youtube channel is
bright insight like and subscribe leave
me a comment let me know what your
thoughts are and I have many other
videos to come and a whole wide variety
of topics take care everybody